hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
answer a question from one of our forum
moderators and administrator actually GT
who is asking question about online
advertising so wrote insane I've always
been a believer in the purpose and value
of advertising but I've never been
confident in pain for online advertising
because of earlier attempts and
promoting my business this way are not
experiencing any success with it when
you talk experienced marketers some say
it works some say it doesn't I say it
might depend on where you advertise do
you have any paid advertising online how
do you side when and where to advertise
and who to trust or believe the
advertising operas and promotions GT so
thanks for the question GT I know a big
issue a lot of entrepreneurs face is how
to promote their business and online
advertising is actually one of the most
effective ways if you do it right to be
able to promote your business and if you
look at any of these the surveys of the
ink fastest growing companies in the
country you'll find that online
marketing including advertising is one
of the most cost-effective ways that
they use to grow their business and one
of the most effective anyways regardless
of the cost to be able to market their
companies so how I've done it and how it
might recommend you to look into it is
start looking at where you're getting
your current leads from and I'm always
skeptical of dumping a lot of money into
something and not seeing results so I
hate spending money until I'm making
money just a bottom line rule I hate
putting money out until I'm making even
a little bit of money in just to show me
that it works and so at the beginning
I'll always invest a lot of time and
effort into launching something and
understanding and learning it before I
put my dollars into it and I still do
that to this day as much as possible and
just try to put my time and effort
instead of spending any money on it and
if it gets to the point work and make a
little bit of money on it then I'll
invest it to help it grow so what I
would try to do here in this case and
I've looked at it for my own business as
well is I'll start with where am I
getting current leads from even if it's
not a lot and before I start spending
money on one of the social network gains
lights or online advertising I try to
think am I making anything now and I try
to make it work without having to spend
any money on it so we can look at a
couple examples I look at Google a look
at facebook and look at LinkedIn these
are all places where we've done
advertising or now we're currently doing
advertising as well so Google you could
do it through the AdWords account right
you have your ID words on the side helps
drive leads what I try to do first is
see are you getting leads and business
from the search side right if you're
getting some kind of business from
google then it makes sense your
customers are there and to investigate
spending some money on advertising fuel
to grow that if your customers are there
that's where you want to be spending not
only your money but your time right you
want to hang out where your customers
are because that's going to increase
your conversions if you're hanging out
around non-customers and pain to get
your image shown to people who are not
your potential customers which often
happens people just dump money into
advertising then you're probably not
going to get a lot of great results
right you want to hang out where
customers are and spend your time and
money they're moding to them so if
you're getting some results from google
through organic search then i would
investigate on a small scale using the
AdWords account and looking at
investigating new keywords to help drive
traffic to your site you want to be able
to chalk it as much as possible to a
lead so I don't know start to a sale I
don't know what you're selling exactly
but the closer you can get to an actual
sale the better and Google AdWords gives
you tracking abilities to show which
keywords are actually lead into sales if
you actually sell a product then you can
track it right to the sale you can tell
how much money each keyword actually
makes you if your consultant or selling
the service then it may be hard to track
a sale but you could track to see the
contact us page so somebody who clicks
on your contact page is more likely to
be a client or at least a prospect then
somebody who just hits your homepage and
bounces so you want to be able to try to
track your leads as much as possible
it'll show you quite clearly which
keywords generate money and which ones
don't and the benefit of this which I
really enjoy is
you there's two parts one if it works
you can expand right so start with a
small budget keep testing out on a small
budget see if it works or not and if you
know you're getting organic searches and
that's leading to sales for you then
there should be a way to make it work on
the advertising side you just have to
keep experimenting with it on a small
scale again before you expand it if you
can show that it can work on a small
scale then you can dump more money into
it to expand the other great thing I
love about the AdWords side of things is
if you think about your own experience
you click more on the ads you click more
on the organic results I'm or the
organic results so the challenge here is
it can be really hard to rank
organically it take you a long time to
rank organically for different keywords
but if you can advertise for them and
show that you're making money from
advertising then you can invest your SEO
efforts in your content creation efforts
in to try to rank for those keywords
you're not just showing up for the odd
side but you're showing up organically
as well and that will help drive a lot
more traffic so AdWords is a great way
to be able to test different keywords
before you start your SEO efforts in
your content creation efforts on your
own website so that's Google if you look
at Facebook's we do a little bit of
advertising there as well again same
thing are your customers there you are
you are the people who you want to reach
hanging out on facebook if they are then
that's a potential option for you if
they aren't then don't waste your time
on it just because someone else is
advertised on my facebook doesn't mean
you have to so you have to make sure
your customers are there if they are a
great thing about facebook advertising
is you can really target your
demographics well so with google all
you're doing is targeting certain
keywords where with facebook you can
actually target demographics so people
who live in the United States to live in
Canada or this certain age you are
married or not or part of different
groups have certain interests so you can
really hone in on types of people who
you want to reach a quick example that
i'll use for local business so my wife
runs a salsa dancing company here in
toronto and will have different events
so sauce events with child events which
is another type of dance and if you
wanted to advertise for it you could
pick people who live in toronto
who have an interest in salsa or bachata
or salsa music orbit chatter music and
you can show those people in
advertisement and so it's a great way to
be able to target people and promote
different events compared to doing a
search on Google so that's a great way
to be able to reach people again make
sure your customers or that the last one
I would look at is LinkedIn so something
that we do a little bit of advertising
on and with LinkedIn again you want to
make sure you're getting some traffic
from there I'd invest your time in
posting a linkedin posting on different
groups try to get involved and see are
you getting any kind of results here
right if you're spending some time and
effort and you're not getting anything
back it may mean that your customers
aren't there and you know if you spend
money in advertisements gonna be a waste
of money so what I've done is we have
our profile on linkedin and I'm active
in a couple groups and we get some
feedback from the members and it helped
generate some business so we've done a
little bit of advertising there and what
I love about LinkedIn is you can target
specific companies so you can say I want
to work with if you want to target
Microsoft you want to target Google you
want to target hewlett-packard whatever
the company is you can target those
companies or ranges of employees so if
you want to target fortune 500 companies
you can say okay people with 10,000
employees plots and 5,000 employees plus
you could target industries you can
target job titles so if you want to be
able to reach out to the HR managers
across companies with 5,000 plus
employees you can do that from LinkedIn
and so again it allows you to really
target your advertise in a way that you
can't do on Facebook and you can't do
through google so wherever you're
advertising online there are lots of
opportunities you will the potential to
make money but again i'd make sure that
your customers are there if they are you
hang out there spend the time get
involved being active member of the
community and if you're getting some
kind of leads even if it's a little bit
then it may make sense to ramp it up ooh
advertising if you're not making
anything then I wouldn't waste my time
and my money by investing into an ad
campaign when you do get Sarah with
advertising start small prove that it
can work before you dump a lot more into
it so start small test again
spend a lot of time refining your target
market refining your keywords or finding
your message and when you find one that
works then it's easier to put money into
expand it so hopefully that helps GT
good luck with your online advertising
for those of you watching if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
makes one of them more of these videos
for you and if you have a question for
me I'd love be able to answer for you I
leave in the comments below and if you
just want to leave a comment this tell
me what you thought about I really
appreciate it too so thank you and I'll
see you on the next episode
you